Jocko.
Have you ever had a person you couldn't
get through to someone that you couldn't
manipulate? Then what? What do
you do when you can't get through?
Well, yeah, of course. Um,
I've had people that I could not get
through to and generally speaking,
these people, I like level 12 arrogance.
That's what they are. Giant ego.
That's what causes this.
There was quite a few seal
leaders that I dealt with.
I shouldn't say quite a few.
There were several seal leaders that I
dealt with that were like that and have
several business leaders that I've
dealt with that I would like that.
In podcast number five,
I read that counseling letter,
corrective measures to a guy that was
really arrogant and despite that letter,
he did not change and he got fired.
So what do you do when you got someone
that you can't get through to you?
You fire them. What if they're, if,
and here's what you gotta do is what
makes that tricky is that some people,
and this May this,
this make people freak out.
There's some people that is such good
performers that even though they're
slightly negative on maybe
their team participation,
but they're so good that that
offsets their negativity, right?
And that happens. It happens. You
know what happens with sales people,
sales people are, are in order to be in
a sales position, you gotta be confident.
You gotta be aggressive. You've
got to be somewhat arrogant, right?
You got to believe in yourself.
And so some salespeople take that to
the extreme where they're just like,
I don't need to listen to what you're
telling me. The new procedures are,
screw that. I'm the one that's
doing the big dollars over here.
How much you follow my procedures,
boys, right? So, so that happens.
Well then what you gotta do
is you've got to look, does,
is this guy producing so now that can
create problems within their team.
And you have to balance those
things. Is this guy, uh,
is the negative media,
is creating offset by the awesome
productivity that he's doing.
And furthermore, if the
guys that good, hey,
maybe we should be modeling some things
after them. I got no problem with that.
If you're the best performer,
cool. I want to imitate you.
I want to get my people to imitate you.
So that happens at the other
place where you might see it.
A similar situation is a leader that
does really good with their relationships
down the chain of command,
for instance,
but really has bad relations up
the chain of command. So again,
you've got to ask yourself,
okay, if I fire this leader,
how many of these people that he has great
relationships are now going to leave?
And what kind of detriment
is that to the team?
The that can also happen with someone
that's doesn't debt tweets their people
like crap, but up the chain of command,
everyone thinks he's great and end.
He's getting the mission done by the way,
right?
He's a slave driver and he's creating
total animosity between him and his team,
but he's accomplishing the mission.
So now what do you do? There's risk.
Everyone could quit,
there's rescue could fire them,
and now you don't accomplish
the mission anymore.
This is why leadership is hard and this
is why you have to balance everything.
You have to balance those things,
but talked about it a bunch of times.
If you get someone, you coach them, you
mentor them, you do everything you can,
you have flank them, you do
Jujitsu, mental Jujitsu on them,
you try and get them squared
away and eventually if you can't,
you weigh against, you know, how
it's gonna affect the situation.
And then in many cases you got to
let them go. And we fired, you know,
we fired five,
saw plenty of seals,
get fired from leadership
positions. Um, and,
and same thing with, you know, obviously
you work with consulting businesses.
We see all kinds of people getting fired
because they're either not capable of
doing their job,
they're too arrogant and
they don't recognize that
things are going sideways and
they're just thinking that they're
doing everything perfectly. No,
that's not gonna work out well
for you. Hmm. Yeah. What did,
um, I think his life, he said no,
someone asked him, uh, you
know, when do you know, when's
that line where it's like,
when it's time to fire someone.
And he was like, in a nutshell,
there's a lot to it, but in
a nutshell, which I thought
was dope. Um, he said it's,
you know, you're at that point when
we were, you fire someone when, um,
when you don't feel bad about it,
right? So it's like, yeah, you,
you every tried everything. And,
and there's also people boots,
there's some validity to this that say
the first time you think you should fire
someone, you should fire them. That's
the other end of the spectrum, right?
And what that means is when you're looking
at someone and you're going, man, okay,
I can save them, I can help them. That's
the kind of advice you'd give to someone.
That's, that's a, that's got
a maternal instinct, right?
That you meet someone,
Hey,
I know what this guy is just a good guy
and everyone on my team is great and
everyone's going to do a great job.
You can't tell that person what
Lafe and I normally tell people,
which is when you feel good about it,
you should fire him because that person
will never feel good about firing
anybody just to ball. Okay. See what I'm
saying? Cause he just said, done this guy.
I know he's going to make it. He's, no,
he's going to come around, you know I,
and then they, then they start playing
the, the extreme ownership game, which is,
you know, if I would've given
echo a better direction,
he would have been able to do this.
It's my fault.
I've given an echo 17 re iterations of
this and he still didn't complete it
correctly. He's fired. That's the
way it works, right? There's, yeah.
So the balance, so that
spectrum of, of, you know,
being within the confines of
being justified, firing somebody,
a certain type of person, you got to say
when you don't feel bad about it. Right,
right. I mean, that's like a
fire heavy type dude. Right.
But there's also someone,
the reason you shouldn't feel bad about
it is because I've done everything I can
do to help you, which takes work.
It takes effort. It takes tact.
It takes hard conversations because
it's hard for me to go and say, Echo,
you know, I've been, I've been looking
at your videos lately and they're,
they're not really what we're looking for,
right?
And I don't want to say that to
you. You know, it's uncomfortable.
And we're kind of like, you know, we, we,
we want to get along. So instead I'm like,
yeah, I called that. That video
was good, man. Yeah, it's good,
but I'm not telling you the truth.
And then over time,
our videos are looking good enough. And
eventually I said, you know what? No,
we're not.
No one's buying our videos anymore
and we haven't gotten a new contracts.
So guess what? I'm going to have to
let you go. And you're like, well,
you're talking about, you said all
the videos I made were good. No,
you're firing me. Maybe you
need to be able to become a
better salesperson. Right?
Whereas if I had the hard conversation
early and said, hey, echo, you know,
I know you're creative
and I appreciate that,
but we also need to get the
message across for our clients. Um,
obviously fabricating of business
where we're making videos for clients,
which I know we don't really do a lot
of anymore. Occasionally you do. But uh,
but yeah, you got to, you got to, um,
have the harder conversations earlier.
If I'm the type of person that doesn't
like to have the hard conversations,
once again, I never feel good
about it because I never,
I never gave you any advice. So it always
feels bad for me to fire someone. Yeah.
But if you're following
good leadership tactics,
then absolutely true. When you get to
a point where you gotta fire somebody,
you won't feel bad about it because you
know, you've done everything you can,
you know,
you've coached and mentored them and
you know that if you keep them on board,
you are negatively impacting
your team, which is bad. Yeah.
And then go down to the other side of
the spectrum still within the confines of
being justified in firing somebody,
by the way.
But on the other side of the spectrum,
you get how you say that,
what do you call the month
maternal instinct type of
person. The person who can,
like, they're just super hard on
themselves maybe, or they're, you know,
like I even if you did do
everything you can, you still like,
I could have done more,
you know, so it's my fault,
not his kind of feel like I let them
down as a leader gave them 17 counseling
chits. Yeah. You know, they don't belong
here. They can't do their job stop. Yeah.
Meanwhile they're going home laughing
at you or whatever. But yeah,
you get that kind of personality.
So it's kind of like how you say,
you got to balance it. You gotta be
like, okay, you gotta recognize, okay,
what kind of person am I,
you know?
Or what kind of person is this
other person kind of thing.
And if they're those maternal instinct
jewel for lack of better way of putting
it a person,
then what was it the first time
you feel like you should fire him,
you should fire him. You hang out on that
side of the spectrum. You've got it. Yup.
Yeah.
Yup.